hi I'm Erik Bosse and the Black Widow
movie's plot villain and characters are
starting to be revealed thanks to some
images from the next major film in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe pipeline the
first movie of Marvel phase 4 even if
it's hero was killed off in Avengers
endgame and given no funeral or you know
how maybe she was somewhere and we just
didn't see it like the kind of secret
funeral a Soviet spy gets which I just
assume is something super heartbreaking
like in Chernobyl oh god I'm gonna break
down all the new details we have learned
about Black Widow it's story it's cast
and how it will connect to the MCU
timeline it's more the warning in case
any my speculation ends up being too
accurate or generally okay so a Black
Widow Scarlett Johansson movie has been
in development for a while but only
started to really move forward in 2017
when Marvel Studios hired screenwriter
Jack Schaeffer to write a script later
Ned Benson was hired for rewrites they
have hired Australian filmmaker Kate
Shortland to directs best known for
directing a Nazi period film called war
and this Black Widow film will also be
apparently set in the past as a prequel
perhaps sometime around the year 2006
this would be 15 years after the fall of
the Soviet Union where Natasha Romanov
got her start as a KGB operative but it
would also be a few years before iron
man would have arrived on the scene
before Tony Stark met Nick Fury and
Natasha Romanov in Iron Man 2 and before
the whole Avengers initiative came
together to fight the forces of Loki and
setting this all in the past seems like
one of the only ways to do a Black Widow
movie at this point since you know she
died and was left to rot on vermeer
unless you get into some like alternate
reality trickery also possible we know
from various lines of dialogue
throughout these movies and flashbacks
in age of Ultron met Natasha Romanov
began her life as a KGB trainee she was
brainwashed into a merciless assassin
while taking some creepy ballet classes
as an elective but now this story will
featuring Tasha with a cast of new
characters including Florence Pugh who
has reportedly been cast as a spy that
is the moral opposite of Natasha and it
looks as though pew we plane Yelena and
Belova perhaps the most popular side
character from The Black Widow comics
yelena is a younger Russian spy who
targets Natasha hoping to take the title
of Black Widow
away from her and video has depicted
Natasha riding a motorcycle with a
blonde haired woman
suggesting that this could be Elena and
perhaps these two spies could be
in conflict and working together in this
movie supply the cast will also feature
david harbor from stranger things the
actor Ray Winstone from the departed and
ot5 in lay from The Handmaid's Tale
Rachel Weisz is also rumored to be in
talks for a role in Black Widow and with
her Oscar wins and recent award
recognition for the favorite last year
you've got to think this heavy hitter is
being set up as a major figure in this
story I'll get to who that could be in a
moment but first thank you to our
sponsor curiosity stream for helping us
make this episode curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service made for
those of you who have no shame in your
nerd game with over 2400 documentaries
and nonfiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclusive originals with content hosted
by names like Stephen Hawking and David
Attenborough
I've really enjoyed watching the
Sigourney Weaver narrated docu-series
dream the future which explores cutting
edge developments in medicine energy and
consumer technology to show how the kind
of sci-fi concepts we imagine in TV and
movies could actually be a reality by
the year 2050 in which I will be the
ripe age of 28 don't do the math
curiosity stream is available worldwide
on platforms like Apple TV Roku iOS
Android Xbox one Smart TVs chromecast
Amazon fire Amazon Kindle and web app
get unlimited access starting at just
$2.99 a month and for our audience the
first 31 days are completely free if you
sign up at curiosity stream comm slash
new rockstars and use the promo code new
rockstars all one word lowercase no
quotes during the signup process okay
back to Rachel Weisz is character in the
black widow movie I'm thinking a major
Hollywood figure like her will be cast
as a villain character since a listers
tend not to sign on to these movies
unless they're playing title heroes or
villains like Cate Blanchet or Josh
Brolin did the set photos have shown
glimpses of a possible villain this
armored figure riding in a tank like
vehicle now the armor makes it hard to
tell the build could be that of a female
we don't really know if this is Rachel
Weisz or not but some are speculating
that the villain of Black Widow could be
a version of taskmaster from Marvel
Comics
taskmaster can mirror the exact attacks
of his opponents move by move now the
taskmaster that we've seen typically has
a hood in a cape but some depictions
have emphasized the bulked up armored
look others are speculating that this
could be the villain Knight Thrasher
who's a recurring Marvel figure with
the Hellfire Club from the x-men comics
and yeah it's also possible that Vice
could play a non villain role like some
kind of mentor figure similar to a net
benning's complex role in Captain Marvel
perhaps some higher ranking KGB
operative whom Natasha must overcome and
all of these set photos are coming from
Budapest which is a big deal because
that city has come up a number of times
in past Marvel films as the location of
some past mission that Natasha
experienced with Clint Barton Hawkeye
and recently in Avengers in game when
Clinton Natasha were headed to go get
the soul stone Flint again brought up
Budapest so the fact that this Black
Widow movie will be set in Budapest
suggests that this is the mission that
she was talking about with Hawkeye and
Jeremy Renner could make a cameo in this
film as well based on their exchange in
the first Avengers I'm guessing Budapest
here will turn into a deadly war zone
and shootout in Black Widow motorcycle
and tank chases through city streets
maybe something like the third act of
The Dark Knight Rises and Hawkeye might
not be the only returning little cameo
from the MCU Nick Fury as revealed in
Captain Marvel earlier this year did
some time in Budapest during the Cold
War when he told Carol he used to be a
spy then spy where was a cold war
everywhere
Belfast Bucharest Belgrade Budapest I
like to be a second make them write
rhyme theory all those cities starting
with B doesn't make them Rimel it makes
them alliterative Bucharest and Budapest
I mean is just coming to dinner on Nick
Fury how many times do you want me to
correct your grammar last now to be
clear Captain Marvel was set in 1995 and
Fury's cold war Budapest adventure that
he talked about would have been sometime
in the 80s when Natasha would have just
been a girl and probably not in the main
events of this movie When Natasha is
clearly an adult but it is possible that
fury could return to Budapest and help
out with his old Budapest contacts or
safehouses or maybe Nick Fury could show
up at the end of the movie or in a
post-credits scene to recruit Natasha
and send her on a mission to do what
infiltrate Stark Industries and cave
both eyes open on the Iron Man and it
sounds like Black Widow will be the film
to drop on Marvel's next scheduled
release in May 2020 but what other
character would you like to make a wool
cameo in black widow comment down below
with your thoughts and follow me on
instagram and twitter at EI vas and
subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdown to theories of everything
Marvel related thank you for joining me
and just to be sure the black widow
movie is a prequel let's check in on
etosha son buried corpses on Vermeer yep
she's still there
[Music]